is
yep
agenda item one apologies for absence
i haven't got anything
thank you
there aren't any substitute members
provide like gender item two
agenda item three we have
councillors roger constable
jim cripps
yeah no i don't need you to uh signal um
we've got
councillor julie goody we haven't got
james gooding
[Music]
simon woodson
councillor newport mr newport
councillor
wilkinson
yeah i'm just looking have we missed
anyone else oh councillors
thank you that's it have i missed any
other councillors
no thank you
a gender item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of february
are the meetings agreed members
thank you
gentlemen
agenda item five to receive declarations
of interest
uh council
i have a declaration for item nine
that are non-binary that i do know um
the owners of the property no sorry it's
not
it's the council offices item seven
non-vacuumery
but even for that one because they're
personal friends
that's fine okay so right
cuts are sure and i do not need to do it
thank you
members before we continue with the main
business of the meeting i would like to
move a motion without notice in line
with committee procedure rule 9c
to take
that's newport
mike
thank you chairman um just take some
advice from the monitoring officer as a
member of rayleigh town council do i
need to declare an interest
for everything yes thank you
yeah
angela sent out last thursday for all
members of
the council
we had dispensation
as uh i'll continue
um i'd like to move a motion without
notice in line with the committee
procedure rule nine c to take items nine
and ten relating to the civic center
hockley road
uh hockley wrote rayleigh first do i
have a second to please
thank you
all members agreed please raise their
hands
agenda items nine and ten members
katie fowler has sent the office of
officers reports which include
information for both items nine and ten
and i
is seeking listed building consent for
the same application
but please be mindful these will be
voted on separately so we will hear um
all the facts
from about the applications but we will
vote on them separately thank you
katie
thank you chairman
uh
so the application is for the demolition
of modern extensions to the civic suite
and the erection of a block of nine
flats and three dwellings with
associated parking amenity space and
ancillary buildings
as can be seen from the location plan
the site is enveloped by hockley road
webster's way and bull lane
is within the rayleigh conservation area
and adjoins two that excludes
barrington's which is this building here
the site borders along highfield
crescent to the east and ball lane to
the south
it is understood that the beacon house
to the southwest site is made up by
residential properties
so this is this building down here
um and if we just look at this
photograph just for a bit of context
this building here fronts onto webster's
way and is believed to be a commercial
unit but this building here is believed
to be a residential unit
so to the west of the site is
burley house which is just located here
and this is understood again to be made
up by residential flats but also a
surgery and just looking at this photo
of the internal we're presuming this is
the door to the residential flats and
then this is the door to the surgery
uh so the site is also within close
proximity to the grade 2 star listed
holy trinity church and the grade 2
listed old parish rooms and barrington's
cottages
the existing site is made up by
barrington the civic suite and the car
park and amenity spaces to the rear
planning permission and listed building
consent is sought for the demolition of
the modern extensions to the rear of
civic suite so these are these
parts here hatched in red
these are the 1964 extensions referred
to in the report
the building containing those council
chambers and members library would be
maintained and altered to accommodate
the change of use to office
accommodation so this is this part of
the building here
these alterations include the
insertion of a staircase
toilets
the removal of some of the walls who
accommodate a doorway and alterations to
fenestration on the south and eastern
elevations
a number of trees would also be removed
and these can also be seen on the
demolition plan as well as the retaining
wall
that joins to the market car park
planning permission is also sought for
the construction of
two buildings referred to as block two
and block three
block two would front webster's way and
this can be seen the front elevation
here on the bottom right for this plan
so it would block two would front webs
this way and the ridge height would step
down to follow the topography of the
street it would be two-story with dormer
windows serving the loft space as a
third floor
there are a number of gable and
projections as well as a bay window
featuring feature fronting websites way
block three would be
situated on the corner of webster's way
and ball lane and would form an l shape
block three would encompass staggered
heights to follow the topography of the
site plot 3.1
which fronts webster's way would be
two-story with dormer windows and
serving the
uh which would serve the lost space the
two two dwellings facing bull lane would
be also be two-story so this is the
property facing webster's way and this
one here would front borlane
uh during the course of the application
amendments were sought to the design of
blocks two and three which included the
reduction in ridge height removal of
flat roofs and replacement with pitch
roofs and alterations to the dormers to
be policy compliant so the plans depict
the this red line which was the height
of the original submitted buildings if i
just go back to the one to block two we
can see that on these ones as well so we
see how the building has been reduced to
accommodate for that
in addition the scheme also proposes the
construction of three ancillary
outbuildings so we can see these here
we've got the bin store the cycle store
and the plant stool
the enclosure and incorporation of part
of market car park into the site is also
proposed to facilitate additional
parking spaces
and here we have the visualizations of
how the new buildings would appear
within the street scene of webster's way
so this one is taken from the top of
webster's way
positioned in front of
the holy trinity church looking down
webster's way
and this one is taken looking up
webster's way so we can see the holy
trinity church in the background there
the key material considerations are the
impact on the conservation area and
nearby listed buildings impact on
residential amenity amenity spaces
highways and parking trees and drainage
it is considered that the impact that
the development would have upon the
nearby listed buildings most notably
barringtons would be acceptable the
development would not be considered to
adversely impact the setting or
significance of any nearby listed
buildings
the amendments sort have reduced the
height of the development to below the
ridge height of barringtons so that the
building is considered to have a greater
subsidiary appearance than was
originally submitted
in light of these amendments which have
been discussed and are outlined in the
report place service existed buildings
and conservation officers have withdrawn
their initial objection and are now in
support of the application
in addition the application is
considered to improve the appearance of
this com area of the conservation area
members may be aware that the rayleigh
conservation area appraisal identifies
this area as unattractive and the most
problematic part of the conservation
area it has been considered that the
development would provide an attractive
addition to webster's way establishing a
function to this part of the
conservation area as opposed to being
used to service the high street the
increase in rich heights of the
buildings rising up towards barrenton's
would draw the eye towards the holy
trinity church and this is a
relationship that is well established
within the historic plan of
raleigh high street also
in light of this officers consider the
proposals would therefore be compliant
with the mppf
the impact upon the neighbours to
highfall crescent and bull lane have
been given considerable weight within
the application
it has been considered that the
development would not amount to an
unreasonable impact upon the
neighbouring properties a separation of
over 35 metres would be maintained
between the block of flat and the
existing dwellings which is considered
to be an acceptable relationship and
appropriate for the town centre location
and just for reference this is block 2
here and so the 35 meter distance is
with regard to the properties on bull
lane here and then highfill present
which are just outside of
the map
the proposed dwellings within block 3
would be compliant with the council's 45
degree test which ensure no unacceptable
overshadowing occurs
so this is this block down here
it is not considered that an
unreasonable degree of overlooking would
occur given the development is within a
town center where it is felt that there
would be an unacceptable overlooking
this can be troubled
can be controlled by planning condition
requiring these windows to be obscure
glazed and fixed shut below a height of
1.7 meters which has been applied here
in relation to the second floor windows
of block 2 facing high field crescent
so these are it's on these at this
elevation here and the first and second
floor windows on the southern elevation
of block two seven the lounges which is
this elevation here
in addition a condition has been
recommended to install a fence along the
common boundary with number one build
lane to preserve the mention of these
occupiers and this is this boundary
along here
the proposal is therefore considered
compliant with policy dm1 and dm3 of the
development management plan in this
regard
the um
the proposed flats would be provided
with an amenity space between block two
and barrington's which is outlined here
the dwellings within block three would
be provided private to main spaces which
can be seen just on the lower part of
the map and
are separated by the orange line
boundaries
the garden sizes would for the most part
be compliant where the amenities space
of plot 3.1 would be below the
requirements is considered that given
the town centre location and proximity
to king georgia's playing fields the
division would be accepted in this
circumstance and it's just this plot
here that is below that
the application site would
provide 15 car parking spaces for the
residential properties this being two
spaces per dwelling and one space per
flat a historic agreement requires 20
car parking spaces to be maintained for
barringtons and a further 10 car parking
spaces were provided for the commercial
use within the civic suite
and on this map it clearly
depicts how they these would be
displayed on site so the residential
spaces would have a different color
paving to the commercial spaces so that
the differentiation is
is clear
so the number of spaces proposed here
are considered acceptable there would be
a loss of 18 spaces within within the
market car park but this is also
considered acceptable the survey
conducted by rochefort council in 2019
has allowed for the application to
conclude that the other car parks within
the rayleigh town centre would be able
to facilitate the loss of parking
the commercial spaces within
with
within the application site would be
available to the public during the
weekend
it should be noted that as the survey
was conducted in 2019 it is considered
that the use of these car parks would
now be less than at the time of the
survey due to the impact of covert 19 on
the high street the development is
considered acceptable by district
officers and the county highway
so the development would result in the
loss of six trees including the loss of
a sycamore and oak tree and if i just
return to the demolition plan we can see
that this is the sycamore tree here and
this is the oak tree that would be lost
the loss of the oak tree has not been
objected to due to its poor health
however the council's agricultural
officer has objected to the loss of the
sycamore tree the council did enter into
discussions with the applicant in the
hope of being able to retain the
sycamore however due to the heritage
constraints on the site the buildings
have had to comprise a greater footprint
than height in order to make the scheme
viable therefore the applicant was not
able to retain this tree there are 10
trees proposed to be planted and
officers have included a condition on
the addendum which has required these
trees to be planted with a heavy girth
of 16 to 18 centimeters to mitigate the
loss of the existing trees as far as
possible
it has also been queried with the
council's agricultural officer about
whether the sycamore could be moved and
replanted elsewhere in the site however
the officer considered that given the
extent of the roots of this tree it
would be difficult to find an
appropriate area within the site to
facilitate this
in addition a condition has been
recommended to plant an additional tree
between plots 3.1 and 3.2 so this is
just at the bottom of the site here
to provide further amenity from the
landscaping scheme therefore it's
considered that given the constraints on
the site the development would be
acceptable in compliance policy dm-25
part of the site to the immediate rear
of the existing civic suite building is
located with an area of high surface
water flooding and that is approximately
uh this area just here
can you
buy the bin store
yeah um
the scheme would use bypass separators
and an attenuation geocellular crate to
achieve a sustainable drainage strategy
in light of additional information that
was submitted by the applicant the lead
local flood authority have withdrawn
their objection and is considered that
the scheme would appropriately manage
surface water runoff and not increase
flood risk off site
there are matters on the addendum
chairman including additional planning
conditions amended planning conditions
and additional neighbor consultation
letters and members will see on the
addendum that there are amendments to
conditions 2 13 15 and 16 as well as
three additional conditions which are
numbers 29 30 and 31 relating to the
impact and trees
the application is recommended for
approval subject to a legal agreement
set out in the heads of terms
in the report and the conditions within
the officer recommendation subject to
those amendments on the addendum and the
occlusion of three extra conditions and
can members know a minor change to
condition six to change the wording from
block one to block uh to block two
thank you
we have three speakers uh public
speakers for this item
uh the first one will be councillor uh
deborah mercer from raleigh town council
you have five minutes
and
i will let you know when you've had four
and that will reply to all speakers
tonight
thank you
thank you madam chairman
the district council has proposed
replacing the civic suite with nine new
homes in a low-rise apartment block
three townhouses and a new office block
on the site next to btmk toblen
solicitors the solicitor's office is
housed in barrington's a grade two
listed building built in the mid-19th
century and situated in the rayleigh
conservation area within close proximity
to another grade two listed building the
holy trinity church
the town council would like to object to
proposals made on several points the
scheme is not sympathetic to the
adjacent grade 2 listed building under
the national planning policy framework
16
190c the desirability of the new
development making a positive
contribution to local character and
distinctiveness it fails to preserve the
character or appearance of the rayleigh
conservation area and has the potential
to affect the setting of our heritage
asset along bull lane king george v
playing field
it is an over development of the site
adjacent to a list of building in a
conservation area sbd2 14.4 states that
the scale and form of the proposed
development will be crucial in the
design of a successful scheme and a
development which is out of scale and
unduly obtrusive to the outlook of
surrounding development will be refused
the new dwellings will create an
increase in noise air pollution and
traffic access to the site is on an
extremely busy hockey road as well as
adjacent to the con constantly congested
webster's way and the increase in
traffic from the new residents the
workers in the new office block and the
immunity collections will put further
pressure and pollution on the town not
taking into account the construction
traffic needed to access the site during
the construction process
this the district council's own policy
sbd2 14.2 c states that any access to a
backland site which is in close
proximity to existing dwellings and
would detrimentally affect the visual
and residential amenity of those
dwellings by virtue of noise dust or
fumes disposal of rubbish or create road
safety problems will be refused its
scale for mass
would not preserve the character or
appearance of the rayleigh conservation
area and the proposed scale of the
buildings will result in an over over
dominant and crowding of the plot
the development is not in keeping with
the street scene and not considerate to
neighbouring properties as set out in
spd 6 3.6 the individual elements of a
new development must be related
proportionally to each other and the
form must be appropriate to its
immediate neighbours and any important
features on surrounding buildings the
parking standards and good practice
supplementary planning documents shows
that there should be a minimum of 23
parking spaces for the residential
development but only 15 has been
allocated the local plan shows that a
number of public car parking spaces will
be lost including two electric charging
spaces which have an impact on a busy
town centre with this land being taken
for the site there are concerns on the
size of the garden spaces for the ten
houses which should comply with spd2 3.2
with two bedroom properties requiring a
minimum of 50 meters square and the
four-bedroom property requires a minimum
depth of two and a half times the width
of the house and a minimum of 50 meters
squared the flat should be in line with
spd2 3.3 minimum balcony area of five
meter square ground floor flat should
have a mini minimum patio garden of five
meters 50 meter square or a usable
communal garden space with a minimum of
25 meters square per flat which equals
225 square meters the grass verge on
ball lane is also to be utilized as
pathways to the dwellings resulting in a
loss of this amenity
mature trees have been earmarked for the
development
of e-mart for removal due to the
location of the proposed apartment
building even though they provide
amenity value and will take years to
replace there is concern over the
protection of tree roots from works and
the drain and the damage that may co
occur from construction
the increase in residence in this area
will have an impact on already
overstretched services such as gps
schools and nhs and dentists raley now
has even less nhs dentists now that the
smile centre will be going private from
the 1st of june 2022 we urge councillors
to reject this proposal on the
objections put forward by the town
council
[Applause]
our second
speaker tonight is mr peter
buiss i hope i've said that right and
he's on behalf of the applicants so if
you would like to come about i do
apologize if i said your name wrong
thank you again you will have five
minutes and i'll let you know
when you're done for thank you
good evening members my name is peter
buist from purcell architects we've been
the architects and heritage consultants
for the application i'm speaking this
evening on behalf of the applicant gb
partnerships rochford
in support of the proposals for the
civic suites site
gbp has been working with rochefort
district council and through the asset
delivery program to bring forward this
application um per sale accompanied by a
full design team of specialist
consultants has been instructed by gbp
to develop the proposals
our proposals for the civic suite site
are for mixed-use development providing
residential and commercial accommodation
the proposals will support the town
centre of raleigh by delivering ongoing
employment on the site as well as
sustainable town centre dwellings that
meet local housing needs
the site comprises the former civic
suite bounded by hockley road to the
north webster's way to the west and bull
lane to the south
and includes a small corner of the
adjoining market car park
the application and associated proposals
have been prepared in accordance with
the policies of the adopted development
plan and the nppf
the proposals are the result of
extensive dialogue with rdc and advising
conservation officers both at
pre-application and application
determination stages whereby design
amendments have been incorporated to
respond to comments received
the proposals comprise the restoration
and conversion of the retained council
chamber block that fronts hockley road
to provide modern flexible office space
the later 20th century council office
extension is proposed to be demolished
two new residential buildings are
located towards the southern half of the
site the grade two listed building known
as barrington's located towards the
north of the site
and to which the retained council
building adjoins is not part of the
application
to the north of the site is the grade
two star listed holy trinity church and
the site itself is located within the
rayleigh conservation area
the application proposes approximately
300 square meters of commercial office
space within the retained council
building
and the new residential buildings will
provide 12 dwellings of which two are
affordable
the new residential buildings have been
designed to remain subservient to the
listed barrington's building whilst
creating a new street frontage onto
webster's way
the separation of the new dwellings from
barringtons and from each other
maintains views through the site along
webster's way
the massing of the proposed new
residential buildings is deliberately
kept below the height of barrington's
with the highest ridge at the central
residential block being one meter below
the ridge height of barringtons
the massing of the new building steps
down towards the southern end of the
site in parallel with the change in
topography
the new buildings are proposed as two
and two and a half stories in height
with upper floors located within roof
scapes so as to reduce the massing
the forms of the new buildings are
deliberately broken up into distinct
blocks to reflect the historic gables
and floor spans that are common within
the conservation area and create a
series of defined frontages and
interesting roof scapes onto webster's
way and bull lane
the new buildings have been designed to
reflect a subservient and subtly
contemporary interpretation of
barringtons materially they are proposed
in white brick with slate and lead roofs
the proportions of new windows draw
reference from the listed building and
the use of traditional timber cladding
reflects the surrounding vernacular of
rayleigh
panels of herringbone brickwork adds a
subtle detail to the elevations
rear-facing windows to the new dwellings
have been carefully positioned to avoid
any overlooking of adjacent dwellings
there are no upper floor balconies
proposed to the new dwellings for the
same reason
the new residential accommodation will
be constructed to a high standard of
energy efficiency using high levels of
thermal insulation to minimize energy
use and utilizing electrical air source
heat pumps for heating
again there will be no reliance on
fossil fuels for the development
the scheme provides 45 car parking
spaces of which 30 are designated for
commercial use and 15 for residential
use
vehicle charging points for the
commercial and residential spaces are
provided with infrastructure laid for
future installations when needed
refuse storage and cycle storage is also
provided within the landscape areas of
the site
the scheme does involve the redesign of
the proportion of the adjacent market
car park this area of the car park is
presently inefficient in terms of
parking space arrangement and therefore
the proposals have been developed to
minimise the loss of public parking
spaces
the existing public electric vehicle
charging points are unaffected by the
proposals
the proposals retain the existing
vehicular access to the site from
hockley road and the transport statement
states that trip production during peak
times will be reduced from the previous
use of the site as council offices
the master plan extends the green space
to the south of the listed building this
area will be used as shared immunity
space and following an arbor cultural
survey of the site all class a trees are
retained on the site
the existing mature trees to the north
and south of barringtons are retained
and the new memorial tree will be
planted with the existing plaque
relocated
unfortunately after many options were
explored the existing tree adjacent to
the bus shelter is proposed to be
removed but in recognition of the loss
of this tree new trees are provided
along the frontage of webster's way as
well as within the site
i would like to thank members for
considering this application
and invite you to support your office's
recommendation to grant consent for the
application thank you
the
members
sorry members of the public can we not
barrack anyone please all i have to ask
you to
remove yourselves
the speakers number three is miss
gabriel peters who is the objector thank
you
and again
ms peters you have five minutes i'll
give you
what you've done for thank you very much
thank you
hello my name is gabby peters and i live
at one ball lane which is directly
adjacent to this
proposed building
i object to the civic suite planning
development submitted by rocha district
council development partnership and gb
partnerships
and i'm here to ask you to reject the
plans
i thank the rayleigh councillors for
sticking up for us and also objecting to
the plans
i know that they have submitted a
spatial options response to the
district's local plan opposing all
development on our conservation areas
i choose to live in raley's town
conservation area for a reason it's one
of the very few green areas left in our
town and this area is designated as
non-residential space
my home was built in 18 in the 1890s
and is and is an undesignated heritage
site and is due to its limited
foundations
it will not be able to sustain the
building work that's planned my home
will forever be damaged potentially a
risk to my safety
my entire home will be permanently
overlooked causing 100 change in my
amenities and as i no longer be able to
use my garden
only including obscure glass on the
third floor of the flats means that the
second floor and both of on of the flats
and the houses will see directly into
every part of my garden and all of my
rear windows
erecting a 1.8 meter fence will make no
difference when every window on the rear
of the proposed flats will look into my
garden and rear windows
my privacy and my neighbor's privacy
will be gone
however a railing is being erected for
the privacy of barrington's todmans and
the proposed flats why are they entitled
to privacy but i'm not
and yet as
i understand the solicitors own the
covenants which gives them the right to
access over the community amenity space
for the flats
and they are sharing them with them
the position of the townhouses and the
flats will reduce the light in my home
whilst these might not be material
considerations in the planning world i
want you all to know that this plant
development has already had a
significant impact on my
physical and mental health and i
personally will bear the brunt of this
development
i understand homes needed but this is
not the right place for them
and the civic suite
was never included in the local plans
flats and town houses are not in keeping
with the current streets seen
and or the character of bull lane my
home and those adjacent are either a two
storeys or bungalows
the listed buildings next to the site
will be impacted i understand the
windows on the civic suite are being
amended from the current aluminium
frames to wood to put them back to the
local look of the area and yet the
proposed flats have aluminium frames
further example of how this is not in
keeping with the environment
i understand one of the council's
pledges is to plant over 30 000 trees a
year
and yet surely destroying the trees that
are here
um and have been here for decades even
centuries cannot be in keeping with this
pledge
while planting shrubs and saplings is a
start it will take too long for them to
do the same job as the already in situ
mature trees
can the magnolias the plum trees the
olive tree
not be relocated along the border of my
property ribs to obscure the view
i realize the sycamore might be pushing
it a little bit
the new properties will bring additional
people and traffic
which will cause more noise and access
to the parking
for the flats sorry
the new properties will bring additional
people and traffic which will cause more
noise and access to the parking for the
flats will cause more congestion on an
already regularly gridlocked road
further additional losses of the public
parking spaces both in the civic site
and the market car part will impact the
overall town this will result in
additional illegal parking along both
ball lane and highfield crescent
the lack of adequate car parking on the
site further demonstrates that this is
an over development within the
conservation area
the development will increase traffic
and impact the air pollution already
already exceeding legal limits in this
area and this cannot be allowed and how
will it be monitored and will any action
be taken if it is exceeded
i'm not able to attend a dentist in the
local area due to the overburdened
service additional people will impact on
that further
finally the corner of ball lane is a
very busy junction
there is no crossing for children to
safely get to king george's park
there have been at least two serious
accidents that i'm aware of in the last
few years this development will increase
the risk in the line of sight and while
i appreciate that the highways have
discarded this from their claim they
should stand and watch this road for
several days and they would definitely
amend their opinion
thank you for listening and i sincerely
hope that you do or refuse this
application that's been put before you
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
i will now ask to give priorities to the
world member which will be councillor
mike wilkinson would you like to speak
yes five minutes again five yeah please
do so yeah so it saves people running
around with my friends
and again counselor wilkinson you'll
have five minutes one minute to go i'll
advise you
chairman uh members of the development
committee there are several aspects of
this proposal which caused me serious
concerns on a personal level i do not
support any resource any residential
housing on this site added to that
more importantly my view the public
perception is that they don't want it
there either
it's their town so quite while we appear
to not be listening to them is slightly
worrying to say the least
but if we park that for a second that
accept there appears to be a political
will to build on the site i will turn to
specific aspects of the proposal itself
i'd like to firstly remind members that
there is a clause within the
sorry to remind members that the the
conditional contract
of the sale for the land specifically
includes a clause allowing the council
to act as a local planning authority
completely independently from any
obligation it may have or may
it may have or may not have made to sell
the land under the contract between
watch district council and jubilee
partnerships so therefore there's
absolutely no compulsion on any member
of this committee to pass this
application due to the contract already
signed
this proposal is being sold to his
policy compliant but i'm afraid i
disagree this site is within the
conservation area of raleigh town centre
the radiator action plan informs us in
1963 the radio civic society was formed
to oppose the inappropriate development
being planned for the town presumably by
the then planning authority
1969 areas of the town including this
site were designated the conservation
area and the policy acknowledges that
it's due to the formation of this civic
society that the heritage buildings of
the town survive today
so five decades ago residents of this
town did their utmost to preserve the
conservation here in raleigh and this
council in 2015 has continued that work
by creating and adopting the radio
action plan policy eight of that plan
states that development within the town
centre should not result in the overall
loss of car parking which plays a
critical role in supporting the
businesses in the town the vitality and
viability of those businesses it states
yet this proposal will see the removal
of 18 car parking spaces out of an
overall total of 73 which exists today
members that's a removal of 25
of the overall parking in that car park
we've been informed about a pre-covered
survey that was conducted personally i
don't recall this survey or any other
residence in radio that i've spoken to
the reduction in car parking spaces i
would suggest is clearly contrary to
policy
the design of the new buildings is
simply not in keeping with the existing
street scene there are some fine
examples of historic buildings within
the conservation area the old school now
um now a restaurant opposite barrington
is being a case in point and whilst i do
acknowledge that peter burris the
architect has made some very valid
points in this subject of the member
presentation last month with respect to
him
this design is far from acceptable in
this location the planned new buildings
will have a negative rather than
positive relationship with the
surrounding buildings which is not only
necessary in all build builds but
particularly when the building within
the conservation area this is contrary
to policy dm1
it is out of keeping with the existing
street scene and therefore contrary to
policy dm3
its design is such that it will have a
detrimental impact on the historic
environment also conscious of policy dm3
members you've heard from gabby peters
who lives next door to this development
in her submission she states that she
will suffer
loss of privacy due to overlooking a 1.8
metre high fence is not sufficient to
provide privacy to her rear garden i
would support her argument that if this
development were to go ahead then there
should be an additional condition of
approval that a line of mature trees is
planted along the entire boundary wall
between number one bull lane and the car
park
chairman members we have seen the other
aspects of this proposal brought forward
as part of the asset delivery program
those in rochford i support i
congratulate the way in which the design
team have worked to design an extension
to the freight house which is totally in
keeping with the existing building yes
in rayleigh we see a proposal that is
totally out of keeping with the location
it is designed to maximise a financial
gain from the site by putting housing on
the land it is wholly an appropriate
design for the location
and personally i'm angry that the
residents of raleigh are being asked to
put up with a design such as this
in our town to finance a sympathetically
designed building in rochford it is not
acceptable and it's not policy compliant
this application plans to remove 18
public car parking spaces to provide
necessary car parking for the new
residents on that site so it's policy
compliant this i would suggest is
indicative the site is being over
developed over developed
reduce the amount of housing on there
thereby reducing the need for car
parking spaces thereby reducing the need
to take public car parking away from the
town
members i therefore urge you to dismiss
this application for the above reasons
the breaches of policy dm1 policy dm3
and policy 8 of the radio action plan
added to that in its current form this
proposal requires removal of a tree
which a professional arbor
harbor
cultural officer pardon me has stated
should not be removed thank you chairman
thank you
[Applause]
i want to go ask
visiting members if they would like to
speak
councillor woodson
thank you madam chairman
and members
i know that you and your colleagues will
quite rightly focus on the planning
aspects of the applications before you
this evening
which relate to three of six component
sites of rocha district council's asset
delivery program
however given the significant public
interest and as a courtesy to the
audience here tonight
it is appropriate to give advance notice
and share the contents of a press
release which will be issued later this
week
as leader of this authority i made a
promise to listen to the consultation
process early last year on site both in
rayleigh and rochford
in may i promise to pause and reflect on
that messaging in order to deliver
positive outcomes
i have done just that and worked very
closely with the partnership panel under
the excellent chairmanship of councillor
robin dre
as a result
i can categorically confirm and clarify
that moving forwards
there will be no residential development
on the mill hall site
the car parks
[Applause]
the car parks either side of the current
mill hall will remain with similar
capacity to the existing
a new superior multi-purpose community
building will be constructed to include
a hall
with seating capacity and flexible space
to accommodate up to 250 people to
replace the existing mill hall
i should add that it is my own
perception that the current building is
unlikely to be able to be cost
effectively refurbished and reconfigured
to meet modern environmental standards
and long-term sustainability
both structurally and financially
however
the option to refurbish will not be
discounted at this stage until further
work has been carried out to give an
informed view
public engagement and consultation is
vital in the process as we move forward
and i assure residents that will happen
albeit i accept consensus and agreement
will not always be possible
thank you madam chairman thank you very
much
councillor paul would you like to come
and
cancel a new poll
yes
again you'll have
sorry you'll have five minutes thank you
members
i believe that in our district it is our
duty as members to promote sustainable
high quality housing developments
that means that we should look to set an
example to private developers
reading this application it falls very
short of these high standards that our
residents expect of us and as such this
application has drawn a huge negative
response from the community
this should carry great weight in the
minds of the committee
in determining
determining this application the
committee should think very carefully
about the ramifications of the location
of the proposed development within our
precious conservation area
would this set a precedent for other
residential developments of a similar
nature and would it be hard for our
council to defend against in the future
this site
is not within our allocations plan
adopted in 2014 and therefore the minor
impact of the hdt
in my opinion is outweighed by the
environmental and sustainability factors
the officers report relies on a
transport assessment which was produced
in december 2021
this does not give sufficient weight to
the new hierarchy of road users within
the highway code which came into effect
in january 2022
i have heard many times that our council
is seeking to promote an infrastructure
first approach to development
a basic requirement is one of healthcare
although the developer has agreed to a
section 106 payment of just 5 700 pounds
i do not believe this will mitigate
the effects of this development
as it stands
and as previously been mentioned there
are no nhs dentists with capacity in
rayleigh
and i have personally contacted mark
francois the mp to look at how the
government and the nhs england will be
able to provide
capacity
as yet i have not received a response to
their future plans
the council would be well advised to ask
the ccg to reassess the contribution
needed to help mitigate the proposed
development
from the officers report page 9.32
paragraph 3.102
states that the application does not
have an air quality assessment submitted
it's an alarming omission given the
regular queuing traffic on
webster's way and the street facing
proposed fenestration
as the whole world has woken up to the
fact that poor air quality is a
life-threatening factor in our
environment here is rochefort district
council accepting a poor application
that dismisses air quality with a simple
the proposed development would not
necessarily
necessitate the need for any required
mitigation in respect of air quality
however it should not be overlooked that
the air quality has also been
it's also been omitted to be referenced
in the construction management plan on
page 9.43 paragraph 2
and makes no provision for the pollution
course through any demolition works
cannot be emphasized strongly enough
that this admission of an air quality
report should be given great weight by
the committee
and i would strongly urge the committee
to refuse the application
in summary
i asked the committee to refuse this
application the committee should stand
up for the residents of our district and
not be complicit
in this wanton destruction of our town
its infrastructure and heritage thank
you thank you
please
thank you can i have the red line plant
the planet
you again you will have five minutes and
i'll let you know when you have a minute
left thank you thank you
i've read the hundred odd uh material
considerations in the committee's report
but i've got limited time so i've had to
narrow it down to four that i think are
most appropriate
number one
non-compliance with mppf policy
paragraph 202
which relates to conservation areas
being reused for something else
the development committee cite
that mppf policy and para 202
but the proposal is non-compliant
i can see no evidence
of public benefits that outweigh the
change of use harm
to the conservation area status
i could see no public benefits
item two
over development of the civic suite site
shown by the red planet now
the proposal drawing indicates a large
scale incursion into the public car
parking area that's the protrusion to
the right
that car footprint
is significant in size it actually
equals the space proposed for the three
intended house houses
at the lower end of the site
i think that's a clear over development
in spilling out of the site
in order to complete housing at the
bottom
on a conservation area
item three
i see
the
use of the public car park as an
unsustainable planning approach
the planning authority know full well
that the existing local plan is still 50
before it's complete which will generate
more loading
there's a second local plan
coming through the system to us which is
double the size of the existing local
plan which will increase loading
there's forever ongoing windfall
developments generating more people
so the load on that part car park is
going to go up not down
and giving up 25 of it i don't believe
is the right way to go that to me is
unsustainable planning and the world
unsustainable appears in the mppf policy
a thousand times
item four
inconsistent parking policy
the nhs scanner unit was charged three
thousand pounds for temporary use of six
bays this proposal sees eighteen bays
in pepper in for life
sacrificed to support a private business
i'm not sure that that is actually a
planning matter i think it's more of a
constitutional issue
i.e
not acting in the best interests of the
public
because apart from the
inconvenience
of
civic parking
that being reduced in the long term
that's a quite huge loss of income
i therefore believe
that this particular development on this
particular site is inappropriate
i therefore appeal
to the development committee to
reconsider
all these aspects
because i believe it will bring a
lasting negative impact on the town
and so i look for a move to refusal
thank you
thank you very much
any other visiting member of the council
do they wish to speak please please
indicate
no so we'll go through to committee now
so we'll go to the world member
um which is mr sorry council of jack
longman sorry
okay yeah
thank you chairman um
i've listened quite intently this
evening and i've heard
a lot of issues brought up which
obviously i've been looking at myself
but before i do anything or say anything
is it
possible sorry so now i didn't want to
interrupt no no sorry
well
i wasn't being rude someone else
indicated
um
before i go into what i want to say is i
wonder if i might ask the officer just a
couple of questions
to clarify something
yeah but you will
you'll be the same as the others you
will have five minutes
okay well with their answer will that
take my five minutes
you've still only got five minutes i'm
sorry you everyone's got five minutes
because this is a long agenda yeah i
understand it but i am a development
committee member anyway the question is
simply this when we had the site meeting
at the weekend when we was given this it
was a very good simon
there was comment made about the car
parking being used by the residents
during the day and at the weekends it
would then be open to the public so i
need clarity to understand that
particular issue because who's going to
run the car bog is it a public car park
or is it a private car park
because if it's a public car park then
why
shouldn't these residents be paying
to park there if it's if it's going to
remain a public car park
should that be there at all or if it's
going to be a private car park how is
this going to be managed that's my
question right stop okay
stop we've stopped the timer so we'll
get your answer
thank you chair um okay so the existing
arrangements for the btmk car park and
the civic suite car park is that it's
an office car park
for
monday to friday between 7 00 am and 7
pm
and then
at the weekends on a saturday it becomes
pay and display
and that is chargeable up until 1 pm
and then after 1 pm it's free
so those parking arrangements as they
exist will transfer onto this site but
it will only be the commercial spaces
which have been shown as marked in a
different
material that will be available for the
public
so there will still be public parking on
the site
so german if i just clarify that then so
what you're saying is the people
at the barringtons will have a pecuniary
advantage over the members of the public
because they can park there freely
monday to friday yes so the council is
going to give up
advantage
well it's the same arrangement that's in
they're not paying for it that's why i'm
getting it
sorry it's an existing um contractual
arrangement uh council lawman but it's
also not material to the planning that
we're considering this evening so
although it's pretty of interest to
councils generally it isn't materials
well it's an existing
arrangement that is going to continue
it's contractual between barrington's
and the council so it's part of the
original um
covenants that exist with that building
so it just continues as it does now
um but it's not a matter of planning
this evening well should i just step in
can i just step in and this was fully
explained at the site visit on saturday
where i was present you asked questions
yeah we asked him but not in detail you
weren't given specific things so okay um
as well counselor have you anything else
to say before i open it up to the rest
of the committee please just one other
question uh just clarify the wall going
down number one ball lane that's going
to be knocked down and made a wooden
fence that you were telling well if i
got that wrong
it's only because my hearing on
um so it hasn't been proposed to be
demolished i've just recommended a
condition on the application to
install a 1.8 meter closed board fence
so that could run alongside that brick
wall to preserve the amenity
so it'd be like two skins sort of thing
yeah if i just scroll down on this plan
so this plan shows that the existing
brick wall along here
would be retained so we have just
conditioned a fence to then be installed
alongside that okay thank you right if i
may now continue
right we never stopped to continue in
council norman it was you you stopped
yourself well i have questions chairman
anyway the point is that um
i've tried to understand all of this and
i don't know if i said if i have to
declare it or what but i am on the asset
management group so
you've been given dispensation yes i
understand that but the public are
listening so i want people to know my
position you've been given dispensation
so you do not need to already say that
um
right to continue on then um
i've looked at this in the best way i
possibly can and i wonder if you could
just really i think the easiest way is
if that picture that artist's impression
looking from bowl lane or either way
yeah
um
what i wanted to say first of all before
we go into this is that we've heard a
lot today by a lot of people about the
conservation area now this goes back
let's be fair to it it was meant this
area has been mentioned in the doomsday
book all the buildings there
barrington's the cottage barrington's
the restaurant if you like barrington's
building half moon public house the
church all our greatest realistic
buildings
it's an important part of this rally
town centre that's why it's
been brought up so many times and that
is why we have a conservation area so i
just wanted to emphasize that because
when i look at that picture there and i
see in in the documents here page 91 919
item 342 there's a comment that says
sp
d6 have also advised as an appropriate
materials for windows and conservation
conservation here is noting that the
windows are one of the most prominent
features integral to building to
right
to for the character and require careful
consideration
now it's already been mentioned but when
you look at that we're looking at black
anodized windows of plain glass so i
cannot see how that
reflects on on the conservation area or
is any sympathy whatsoever for the local
surroundings and then you take the back
of the barringtons and i did ask on the
day of the meeting that you were going
to retain the georgian style windows to
the left-hand side of the rear of the
barringtons but all the others were
again going to be plain aluminium
windows
now
this is an opportunity for when they
designed all of this to
to if you like enhance and
fill in the characteristics of the local
conservation area and when i look at
this and the plainness of the buildings
and then when you look at that picture
that i showed you
and you look from the corner ball name
you can see the other picture yes please
if you look behind those two people
standing here with a child
uh it's just a
two houses locked together
with a plain brick wall and what i'm
looking at here is a totally
unsympathetic approach to the
conservation area and i cannot see and
i've listened intently with interest to
what has been said i cannot see how that
at all meets the requirements of the
conservation area it doesn't just
doesn't gel as as a design but then you
keep talking about these ones on group
on the second block here as houses there
are blocks of flats they're not houses
and so um
i i can't really see how this fits in
with the street scene
it just doesn't gel and if you look
which you can't see there on the other
side of the road buildings on the other
side have got george and sash type
windows
it doesn't comply or is they got no
sympathy with that conservation scene
it's completely out of character now if
we just go on to
the other side which talks about the car
parking which is obviously an issue
if that block one was made smaller
perhaps that car park could have been
squeezed a bit further in behind the
barringtons
but it seems to me that the size of it
pushes the car parking facility out into
the car park we lose a quarter at that
car park
and we keep hearing this about car parks
and flats and all this sort of thing
thank you and then we hear all the time
about how residents compile it nearby
and so on but that is very busy
if you know the area with the restaurant
with the church with
say the british legion halls except top
end you'll have residence visitors park
in there and we're going to reduce the
size of that car park and i just think
it's an over development and i have to
say i can see to what many of the things
that have been said that this is out of
com our feature it doesn't it's
uncharacteristic it doesn't meet the
street scene and i think it's another
development i cannot support this
application
thank you councilor
is there any other
[Applause]
have we any other members council i
thought you had yeah council stanley
thank you you've got again you've got
five minutes council sterling one minute
to go and
yeah
thank you chairman thank you um
i've listened to all the
residents views and and the members
comments
and i've made some notes
believe it or not
um but first of all
i would like to move that we refuse this
application
on the basis of
dm1 dm3 and policy 8 of the action area
action plan
the proposal
the proposal housing development is
contrary to these to this council's
current local plan
which designates this land for
commercial props purposes
to allow this development would set an
unprecedented
and for other town centres in the
district
the development would be out of form and
density which would be out of keeping
with the well-established character
of the conservation area and the and
detrimental to its appearance
and
display
the development would be contrary to
rdc's policy on conservation areas to
the openness of the gardens would be a
great loss to the conservation area
overlooking the neighbouring properties
of loss of privacy from all floors
of the element of that building
that's the center building
inadequate parking provision within the
site for existing and proposal uses as
we already know is of only 15 spaces
with resulting loss of public parking
provision within the town would be
detrimental to the livelihood of the
town centre
the development would be usually
visually intrusive to the outlook to of
two residents of bald lane and high
field crescent and to the conservation
area
the development will be detrimental to
the street scene as we've already heard
in this conservation area and represents
the over development of the site because
of the large bulk of the buildings it
also has minimal amenity space
and garden space and no clothes joint
areas for the flats
lots of trees
there are several trees that we will
lose and to
get the size of those trees back again
we would have to plant
50 60 year old trees which i don't
believe we're going to do
close to main road
we've got no
air pollution monitoring at all
on that corner and we do know that there
is a lot of traffic on that road at busy
times of the day and that includes
saturdays as well where we see the car
parks are full
although the local plan permits us to
put rooms above shops
the policy does not allow
residential developments
in historic in the historic core of
rhodey town count brodytown center
the application goes against this
council's policy for roady town
centre radetown center and the
conservation area so again i move to
refuse this application thank you
[Applause]
for refusal have you a second
stanley can you repeat your reasons for
refusal please
[Music]
reasons for refusal
relate to dm1 dm3 and policy 8 of the
area action plan as well as
inconsistency and over development
yeah can the officers uh
start looking at the officers to respond
to that please
whichever who's got an icon please
[Music]
yeah thank you chair um during
councillor stanley's address to the
committee
we've got overlooking was also mentioned
inadequate parking provision
loss of public car parking
detrimental to the street scene
over development of the site
lack of amenity space
loss of trees
lack of an air quality assessment
submitted with the application is there
anything else
and contrary to brochure district
council's conservation area policy
yeah conservation every policy
oh sorry can't we need to fight on this
counselor's face
yeah and just one further thing out of
keeping with density yeah correct
density
yeah over development
yeah sorry i had also um comments you'd
made in your initial um statement about
the form um
and the sort of scale the appearance of
the building
in the street scene being visually
intrusive in the conservation area
the large bulk of the building
but that all relates to your
conservation
point in terms of it being out of
keeping
would you like to speak again
from this
it's not on council western
you need to go around the now you can
come around the little green little
button
green button
thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman um yes i was
listening again with all the uh
um
by the ward members
and the residents and i totally agree
that so we should be supporting the
residents we should be listening to the
residents and again our support to
council stanley wholeheartedly on this
so therefore i will not be supporting
this application
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you chairman
as often occurs
with planning applications there is a
huge amount of emotion attached to them
i've been around
this planning committee
for
many many years
and i've heard all sorts of arguments
but what i need to do is just remind
members
that whatever the emotion
of this application
is we are here to determine this
application on planning matters
and i don't believe that the case has
been put strongly enough
there are a number of planning issues
that are material
to
the officer recommendation
there are jobs to be created in the
conversion of the council offices
that is
that is something that our planning
policies
seek to promote
there is a demand for accommodation in
the district
this application seeks to provide
accommodation
this space is in a town center location
which is underutilized
and and does not offer significant
amenity value
there is a
building the current what what was the
the
number of the council offices which
doesn't offer
amenity value
to the district and is due to be taken
down as part of this application
each of the formal planning consultees
have not or
are no longer objecting to what is being
proposed
so
emotionally agree or not
in planning terms
which are the terms on which we must
make a decision
in planning terms i see that we have no
option but to agree with the officer's
recommendation so my position in terms
of
councillor stanley's
motion for rejection is that
unfortunately i won't be able to support
you on this because i do not believe
that in planning terms it can be
substantiated thank you
thank you members we've got a motion on
the table for refuse sorry councillor
foster
yes you are of course you are this is a
debate
council reeves you won't be able to vote
on and we're going we're doing nine and
ten so we quote
i don't think so
thank you chairman
um right referring to um the officer's
presentation and page 9.12 paragraph 3.3
um the rayleigh conservation area
appraisal identified webster's way
as failing to acquire any street scene
that could be considered attractive and
is the most problematic part of the
conservation area
on page 9.46 paragraph 4.24
place services and historic buildings
conservation raised no objection to the
demolition of the extension
and i'd agree that demonstrate the
extension as a 60s
brick building is not an attractive site
for the conservation area
but in making that comment they did
raise concerns which they said have been
overcome by conditions that
read the proposed buildings and i'd like
to ask the officers to confirm whether
or not those conditions could be met
and then some practical ones
how long would the demolition and the
building take if approved
knowing that might influence
voting
one of the points that was raised at the
site visit was the entrance and exit to
the site is very tight
even for cars and i wonder
what mitigation would be in place to
handle construction traffic
and finally much has been made of the
loss of 18 parking spaces
but i'd like to ask and understand what
does 18 represent as a percentage of the
parking spaces in rayleigh including um
webster's way and the mill
thank you thank you councilman foster
i'll hand over to the officers
councillors would you like papers for
this meeting
hot thank you
thank you chairman um in regard to the
place services conditions they have all
been put on
the recommended conditions and included
within the report
so with regard to the construction
traffic
it's not a planning material
consideration of how they
the vehicles would access the site so it
hasn't been considered at this stage
and the question about parking spaces
yeah you've um you've asked for us to
work out a percentage um it it's not
that again it's not a planning matter
we haven't got the figures for us to be
able to work out a percentage for you
what we have got are the survey results
that are actually detailed in the report
that actually show that
the market car park is not used to full
capacity
and it was on that basis
may i just come back quickly on that yes
of course the
the point i'm trying to make is that the
loss of 18
spaces are depicted as a big percentage
and actually it's a big percentage of a
small car park
and there are bigger parking spaces
nearby
thank you
is there any other member wishing to
speak
the council fd
that's
thank you chairman just just one real
quick question really i'm sure it's
taken into consideration but i've read
through
the paperwork about number one
ball lane
and i'm sure
that's any development they would have
proper surveys done on number one to
make sure there's no damage to the house
just wanna make sure that's clear
um so it's not a consideration within
the planning application but due to the
proximity of the building that would be
a private matter that the developer
would have to look at
thank you
arthur no sorry
council williams
is there any other member
right we've got emotional table for
refusal members
can i have your hand a show of hands to
accept for refusal
recorded
yes you can
sorry yeah just just before that um we
just want to um come back on uh one of
the points that was raised in uh council
stanley's reasons um is the lack of the
air quality assessment report
the
[Music]
what what was taken into consideration
is that the traffic movements that
already exist at site
would not be
materially increased
and therefore there would no be no
greater impact on air quality
and there is no
and there is no uh the actual sites not
within an air quality management area or
zone
thank you
so what we are proposing um with
agreement is that we don't actually
include the air lack of air quality
report within the reason for refusal
okay thank you
council stanley can you uh the officers
will list out the reasons for refusal
and if you're happy then we will go to
the votes
so that count um
the officers are going to now list out
your reasons for refusal
and if you can say yes or no at the end
please thank you okay so the proposed
development would be detrimental to the
character and appearance of the
conservation area
and due to its design
layout
insufficient amenity space and parking
provision
would be considered
to represent
over development of the site
contrary to policies dm1 and dm3 of the
development management plan and policy
eight of the rayleigh town center area
action plan
and
rayleigh center raley town center area
action plan my apologies
all right and then there's also to be
inserted sorry and we've just had to do
this quite quickly so combined with the
loss of trees and the impact on the
neighbouring property at number ball
lane and what we will also do chair is
make sure that we include the relevant
planning policies that refer to the loss
of the trees it's not been quoted thank
you are you happy with that
we can't keep adding if we've just
i don't recall that i don't recall that
you didn't mention that cancer stanley
we didn't mention that at all
are you still seconding that council of
western thank you
right members we have a motion on the
table for refusal
all in favor of refusal please have put
your hands up and keep them up while the
monetary officer i'm sorry
uh sonja will vote
count the votes
yeah probably right let's see the
numbers first four
members
sorry you couldn't lower your hands
sorry it's not being at school isn't it
um members for against
show of hands please
thank you members
as with
any abstentions
one
that's it thank you
anyone uh the members that wanted their
votes recorded please indicate now
thank you very much
so there's
four
four seven against on one obstetrician
and as i noted before we have one member
that can't vote because he unfortunately
arrived late
thank you
that mention is now lost
so we'll go back to the original
recommendation for approval
so can i have a
recommendation for item 9 is set out and
paragraph 1.1 of the report of pages 9.1
through to 99.9
and with additional conditions 29 30 and
31 set out on the pages three and four
of the addendum and amending conditions
through 2 13 15 and 16 set out on the
pages four to six of the addendum
members can have a show of hands
oh i need someone to second it please
oh counselor phil shaw thank you
members can i have a show of hands for
approval for this recommendation
and can you keep that until they're
counted thank you
members you can allow
members against this recommendation
please have a show of hands
thank you
yeah anyone
i'll ask
any abstentions members
right now who would what members who
want it recorded counsellor mrs newport
are they all the same thank you
you've got one submission
members this motion has been carried at
seven four
four against one abstention thank you
we will now go on to item ten that has
been discussed
through to item nine
with with item nine
let me play
um
so do we have to ask anyone
so um
members of the public can you please
leave quietly please this is a this is a
public meeting but i'd like you to be
respectful
we have been very respectful tonight
thank you
um
just check first because
yeah okay thank you
but we're going to item 10 members i'm
going to ask councillor mercer if she
would like to speak on this one
and mr burst is there anything else you
would like to write thank you
uh members we've had this has all been
debated in uh with
item nine so we're going to go straight
to the vote
so the recommendation is to accept this
recommendation can i have members
i have a shop
so can i have a second to first please
uh councillor fd
and then can i please have a show of
hands for approval of this
recommendation
please help put your hands up until
seven thank you
uh against
abstentions
thank you
anyone what recorded on this one
thank you members
so that's four
seven against four one abstention
and that's been approved members thank
you very much we will now go back
to items six and i think we're doing six
and seven
together like we have uh on
six six and then oh sorry we're doing
six on its own and then we do six and
seven together sorry seven and eight
together okay members
you can't hear this
right if members can not uh members of
public can't talk why because we have
got some people that need the hearing
loop
so we need consideration for those thank
you that's including members of the
committee
item six
is the freight house bradley way
and again i've got our last members that
you've read the um papers and the
addendums
and it will be
all right i'm sorry claire buckley sorry
you're in here i can see you sorry okay
so chairman this application is for the
extension and part conversion of the
freight house to provide new office
accommodation class eg and continued
community use class f2b with associated
parking and landscaping as you can see
from the location plan the site is
located on the south side of bradley way
and west street
it is accessed from west street through
a joint access with the rockford train
station car park located here
to the south of the site is the railway
line and to the east is public open
space
please members of the public can you
please be quiet because we got i have an
indication other members of the public
can't hear the presentation and they are
here to listen to this
thank you sorry claire please continue
to the south of the site is the railway
line and to the east is some open space
and with the reservoir as well
oh claire can you turn up a bit because
i certainly can't hear you i don't think
i can turn it up here but i can move oh
that's better
is that better yes it is thank you
might be better with this one
thank you
so the site consists of the formal
railroad building the freight house and
surrounding car park with some existing
soft landscaping to the east the site is
a locally listed building but not
nationally listed it is located within
watchful conservation area and watchful
town centre
part of the site is within flood zones
two and three but this is limited to the
soft landscaped area towards the eastern
boundary at the red line site so along
this section here this is the actual
railroad building itself a surrounding
car park here and soft landscaping here
and say this is the flood zone two and
three is located right across this edge
here
the site has been identified as a
critical drainage area a very small part
of the site is located within the
greenbelt but this is limited to the far
south eastern corner so we're looking
right at the bottom here down here in a
soft landscape section
moving on to plan three
the proposal is to extend the southern
rear elevation of the freight house a
glass link would attach the two
buildings so you can see the glass link
approximately there and this is the main
extension to the south here
the proposal would also involve the
erection of three new buildings
comprising a visitor cycle store
a visitor cycle store
a refuse store located here and also a
plant room located here
it will also include a pedestrian ramp
on the reservoir side direct from
bradley way so that's located just here
the proposal would involve works of the
existing building including like for
like repairs to the brickwork roof tiles
windows and doors and internal footings
the eastern arch of the building will be
open to connect the glaze link to the
existing building so as you can see here
the area is highlighted red what will be
opened up on the southern elevation of
the building to connect through to the
glaze link which would then link to the
extension
here we have elevations of the proposed
extension it would have a pitched roof
with dual gable lens and in the center
is the glazed link so you can see here
this is the perspective
from the reservoir and open space you've
got the glaze link here and this is the
extension section there and this is the
perspective from the car park so you've
got the existing building glaze link and
then this is the extension here as well
and that's
the plant building as well which would
just be to the south of the extension
the extension would feature large glazed
windows to both the western and eastern
side elevations the external materials
would include red brick with aluminium
framed curtain walling and
windows moving to plan six
as you can see from the ground floor
plan the proposed development will
provide office space for watch for
district council including a formal
council chamber the space will be
adaptable to allow for use by the local
community through the flexible division
of rooms to accommodate a range of
activities by multiple groups
this shows the elevation and floor plans
of the building to the south western
corner so that's located approximately
here on the site
that includes a cycle refuse and asset
store so as you can see here this will
be cycle parking and you've got a refuse
store in the center here and then this
would be an asset store all within the
same
structure and then finally plan eight
this would be the plant store building
so again it looks a similar elevation
design um to the refuse store and that
will be located just to the south here
the key material planning considerations
are the principle of development
impact on the conservation area and
locally listed building
design and layout sustainable design
landscaping
impact on residential amenity access and
highways flooding ecology biodiversity
in trees contamination and air quality
looking at the principle of development
the land south of the freight house has
been identified as an opportunity site
in the rochford town centre area action
plan
the proposed mixed community and office
use is identified as a use that would be
appropriate in principle in this part of
the town centre
looking at the impact on the
conservation area and locally listed
building the application building is
identified as positively contributing
towards the conservation area
the council's historic buildings advisor
raises concern with the proposal however
the harm identified is considered to be
less than substantial and at the lowest
level on balance when considering the
wider public benefits including securing
an optimum viable use of the building it
is considered that these would outweigh
the less than substantial harm
identified
looking at design and layout
the positioning of the extension is
considered a suitable location for the
contemporary extension and maintains the
locally listed building as the most
prominent view from the street scenes of
westerie and bradley way
the proposed link between the existing
building and extension provides a bridge
between the new and old
the scout citing and design of the
ancillary buildings would be considered
acceptable the council's urban design
consultant does not object subject to
conditions
when looking at sustainable design the
restoration of the existing building
would render a very good breed rating
whilst the extension would achieve a
bream excellent rating which is
considered acceptable the plans show an
intention for photovoltaic panels to be
used for the roof of the extension in
accordance with policy
moving on to landscaping the scheme
includes a number of landscaping
provisions including among other things
the planting of 10 trees
it is considered that the proposed
landscaping scheme would create a
visually attractive scheme that helps to
blend it with the surrounding landscape
residential amenity the sufficient
distance between the application
building and the nearest residential
properties in west street combined with
the boundary treatment of these
properties comprising a number of mature
trees would result in the development
having a minimal impact upon these
residential dwellings
on access and highways the use of the
westerly access is unlikely to be any
more intensive the quantum of parking
available would exceed the maximum
figure within the parking standards spd
two cycle stores facilitating a total of
38 cycle storage spaces would be
provided by the scheme in excess of the
parking standards requirement
the quantity of power to wheeler and
disabled pay provision is considered
acceptable
the parking bay sizing as existing on
site would remain unaltered and 10
electric charging spaces are proposed to
the north eastern section of the site
county highways do not object subject to
conditions
moving on to flooding a small section of
the red line boundary would be within
flood zones two and three but all
building works will be located within
flood zone one
a flood risk assessment has been
submitted with the application this
identifies that the surveyed low points
within the site around the existing
freight house building are at a high
risk of service water flooding
the surface water drainage scheme would
include geocellular storage and a
rainwater harvesting system
watchful district council would be
responsible for the maintenance of the
drainage system
the county lead local flood authority do
not object to the surface water drainage
scheme proposed
anglian water have confirmed that there
is capacity to accommodate the increased
foul drainage
looking at ecology biodiversity in trees
mitigation with regards to bats and
hedgehogs has been recommended
controlled by planning condition along
with a recommendation that building
works are carried out outside of bird
breeding season
ecological enhancements have also been
put forward by the applicant
one tree in poor health is proposed for
removal other trees would be protected
during construction works the council's
agriculturalist does not object to the
scheme
contamination a phase one and phase two
assessment have been undertaken and as a
result no mitigation measures have been
considered
necessary and it would be considered
compliant with policy and finally on air
quality it is not considered that the
increased usage of this site would be
significant when taking context with the
existing parking area and building a
neighbouring train station and car park
the site is not located within an air
quality management area
chairman this application is recommended
for approval subject to the conditions
outlined in the report
thank you
we have one speed
one's public speaker on this
this is the piece of bust
i'm going
same format five minutes
and i'll give you a minute
warning
thank you chair
members and officers thank you um i'm
speaking this evening on behalf of the
applicant gb partnerships rochford in
support of the proposals for the freight
house
through its restoration and extension
the freight house is to become a new
civic and community hub representing
both the history of rocha district
council and its future
this new hub will serve the communities
of rochford and the surrounding district
delivering administrative civic and
operational services within a welcoming
accessible sustainable and safe
environment
the submitted proposals are compliant
with all relevant pro policies from the
adopted call strategy and development
management plan and as stated by the
officer the land to the south of the
existing freight house is identified as
an opportunity site within the
rochertown centre area action plan
the application proposals are the result
of extensive pre-application engagement
with
the rdc offices and the wider public
the proposals comprise the restoration
and internal reorganization of the
existing building
a new extension to the south and
landscaping and accessibility
enhancements to the site
the freight house will continue to
provide versatile and flexible space for
many community public and private events
the application includes the
modernization of the three existing
function rooms a new flexible council
chamber is created within the largest
central hall
when not required the chamber will be
dismantled and stored to enable the
large hall and the two other function
rooms to be used for many other public
and private events
the function rooms will be supported by
modern kitchen and catering facilities
bars and servers and secure storage
existing wc's are to be refurbished and
relocated to suit anticipated
occupancies and accommodate simultaneous
functions
the function rooms will be enhanced to
vastly improve the acoustics of the
spaces
each from each function space can be
independently accessed so that events
can be held at the same time without
disturbing each other
the new extension is located to the
south of the site allowing the historic
freight house to remain visible from
bradley way
the new extension will be two stories
high and whilst it is deliberately
contemporary it draws references from
the form
composition and materiality of the
existing freight house the new extension
is proposed in red brick and modern high
performing glazing set within regular
structural bays that continue the rhythm
of the existing building
the new the new extension does step up
in height from the freight house this is
due to the change in ground level to the
south of the existing building
the new extension will accommodate the
council's administrative functions
office spaces meeting rooms and breakout
areas are located across the ground and
first floors
and will be flexible providing various
types of working areas for individuals
and groups
a wide circulation spine accommodates
informal breakout spaces with views over
the nearby reservoir parkland a new lift
will ensure the new extension is fully
accessible to all staff visitors and
public the glazed atrium separates the
new extension from the existing freight
house building clearly defining the new
and old elements of the project
the atrium will be the new public
entrance providing a welcoming arrival
and orientation space
public car parking spaces are retained
on site including 10 electric vehicle
charging spaces the proposals also
include secure storage for both staff
and public bicycles
the application improves the immediate
setting of the freight house which
benefits accessibility and functionality
this is achieved through a new level
access pathway that rises gradually from
the pavement of bradley way to the north
end of the freight house
and new landscaping and trees to the
perimeter of both the new and existing
building softens the boundary between
the buildings and the surrounding car
park as well as as well as adding
further biodiversity to the site
as the officer has noted the new
extension targets a pre-am excellent
rating incorporating a number of
environmental attributes this includes
highly insulated walls floors and roofs
the location and size of windows has
been modelled to optimize daylight into
the new accommodation whilst managing
glare and solar gain
new materials will be selected
demonstrating low embodied energy and
carbon
the roof to the extension is proposed as
100 solar panels generating on-site
electricity
additionally provision thank you
provision of staff showers and cycle
storage will encourage sustainable
travel to and from work
the refurbishment of the freight house
is designed to target brienne very good
this is achieved through new mechanical
ventilation to the function spaces new
lighting and electrical services and
upgrading the thermal envelope of the
building with additional insulation
both the existing and new buildings will
be heated by electrical air source heat
pumps with no reliance on fossil fuels
in summary the project is an opportunity
to create a high quality sustainable
public facility for the communities of
rochford and the surrounding district
i'd like to thank members for
considering this application and invite
you to support your office's
recommendation to grant consent for this
application
we'll give priority to the world members
and it'll be uh councillor mike steptoe
who has indicated that he would like to
speak on this item yep
yep
again councillor steptoe you'll have
five minutes
german could i ask for the um original
location plan to be put up on the screen
if possible please
uh no the other one that showed where
the floodplain was the next one i think
it was
that's the one okay
and is it possible that you could zoom
in in the area
just slightly new north of the existing
building against the road area there
if you can move it a little bit to the
left
that's lovely thank you very much indeed
chairman i'd first of all like just to
say
uh and compliment
um officers and gb partnership i've been
involved with this project right from
its original conception
and i know the amount of work that's
gone on behind the scenes to get to this
stage it has been many years and a
considerable amount of work
and offices and
gpu partnership have taken on an awful
lot of
questions and issues right the way
through the whole process
however there is one particular point
that i am still quite concerned about
and that's the disabled access to the
the building
the existing access comes out through
from rayleigh that actually in
entrance to radio station which comes up
a slope into the car park which is not
suitable really for people in
wheelchairs etc
they
there is
in the plans for to put in a slope from
the northern face of the building down
towards
that area there which is
if members of the public know where
where i mean it's where the five bar
gate to the existing park
is
my concern is that that's
it has to wait a certain requirement of
a slope but
wheelchairs push chairs going down there
does concern me because it is quite a
long slope and it will build up a bit of
speed
secondly
the just to the side of where the hotel
is i don't think it's quite on that
drawing there there is an access route
through to back lane car park
and thirdly
the
there is a couple of roads that come in
there's west street that comes in and
drives bradley way
and there is a zebra crossing which is a
bit further up the road so my concern is
that i don't feel that there's been
sufficient mitigation
where that slope comes out onto the road
about people then trying to cross the
road which is bradley way
first of all to go to back lane car park
secondly to go up into west street
so i have a concern about that
particular point
and perhaps would be interesting to hear
what officers
concerns on that i would perhaps suggest
something like railings or some guidance
for
members of the public when they're using
that particular access so they're
directed along to
where the zebra crossing is rather than
in that busy
bradley way
that is that is my main concern certain
chairman um and i'll leave it to that if
i may thank you very much
how's crips
okay it's a very brief one um
matt
uh harvard white and myself have
established that the
lottery district council conservation
area management plan is about seven
years out of date
um
it currently shows
the freight house on greenbelt
um
which was changed in 2014
as part of the local plan and the
allocations when its
status was changed
so i'm just pointing out that europe the
the
project overall
is targeting multiple
conservation areas
and have a policy that's at least seven
years out date
so i would suggest it needs some sort of
attention
that's it thank you very much thank you
are there any other
visiting members that would like to
speak on this please
no indication
i will then bring it back into committee
and councillor williams as of the war
council
have you
would like to speak
i think the mike's on i can speak thank
you
um yeah it's actually rockford station
councillor scepter not not rayleigh
you had a typo there
um i also have concerns about the
pedestrian access especially for
disabled people i was under the
impression
i think the term would i don't know if
it would be undulating but
a little like um
a swiss mountain road i thought he was
going to go and have some switch back
yeah thank you
um because it is a very steep i know the
error very well and it's very steep and
also the crossings across
bradley way um i fully support what
councillor stepped her says um it's a
very dangerous road and it needs to be
looked at i would like to see a
condition of some kind
that this is given consideration
thank you thank you very much council
have you got any other member that would
like to speak councillor stanley
again five minutes
um thank you chairman um i wonder if we
could put a condition in of the
rainwater harvesting
so that that can be used for
uh to meet the needs of the uh toilets
and and and also for our carbon
neutrality by 2030
and also um can we look at putting a
charging point in for disabled
wheelchairs
should they run out of uh charge i know
we've got only can i stop you sorry
have you read your papers
yeah
6.19 3.5
um i've just missed it now
on 6.19 it says that rainwater
uh 3.57
rainwater will be used to wc new urinal
flushing i missed it i'm sorry i'm
missing okay thank you
thank you sorry
can we also put in something for
charging uh disabled wheelchairs that we
haven't i haven't seen
so can you repeat that sorry
about the disabled wheelchairs yeah a
charging point for disabled wheelchairs
so that's disabled uh not wheelchairs
not sorry not wheelchairs no no
no
mobility scooters yes
thank you
right
counselors can i just get the officers
to answer they want to answer each
question
um members questions and then go back to
for the next one you'll be next okay
so just to come back on the query about
the charging point for disabled
wheelchairs um that would not be a
material planning matter that we could
deal with as part of this application by
condition it wouldn't be appropriate for
us to deal with it in that way as part
of this application okay council
councillors
thank you it's just a important
clarification really um uh council crips
brought an important point uh to uh the
uh uh the committee can i just clarify
what the actual situation is um with
regards to the land
itself now then if if as councillor [ __ ]
says it's seven years out of date what
is the actual situation
on the classification of the land that
we're actually building on please
thank you
it's it's currently unallocated
but within the rayleigh area action plan
it's identified as an opportunity site
rochford sorry rockford towns rochard
area action plan it's because i uploaded
both air reaction plans onto the policy
documents before i came in sorry um the
watchfud area action plan identifies it
as an opportunity site for development
so is it greenbelt
no it's not greenbelt there's the tiny
tiny section of greenville and i'll just
re-point that out so i'll go back to the
location plan there is a tiny section of
greenbelt just to this section here
which is just caught within the site
area but it's a soft landscaped area
just a tiny section here it doesn't it's
not where any of the built form is
located which is all in this area here
is there any other member
wishing to speak
smith are you
just
waiting for the answer from the clarity
regarding the specif the proposed
specification for the ram
whether that's
compliant
so we've just as you've probably seen
we've just been sort of looking into
that and from what we can see from the
landscape plan that's been submitted it
appears that um we have ramps with
flatted areas going up to the actual um
building that's what it's it's currently
being shown so we've got um different
material types for that and the ramped
access is showing a section through here
too
and on top of that there's obviously a
building control matter that um
buildings have an element of to say or
have a disabled access requirement with
them
so we thought that it's
sufficient disabled access is proposed
as part of this application thank you
members we have emotional table
a recommendation for approval
um can i have
i'd like to maybe can i have a second
please
chancellor smith
members can i have a show of hands
for approval and please keep them fixed
up until
sorry just some amendments
through to 6.6 but and there are some um
to approve it
can i have a show of hands please for
approval
thank you members
lower your hands for
against
extensions
thank you members
there's four
four is nine against this one
observation is through that motion is
carried thank you members
now as before we're going to do
seven and eight together
but we will vote be voting on these
separately
okay
now the officer
this is the agenda item for sale street
and the officer is
can you hear me okay yes
um chairman this application is for the
conversion and alteration of the council
office buildings at three to fifteen
south street to form 20 residential
flats
you can't hear
[Music]
so chairman this application is for the
conversion and alteration of the council
office buildings at 3 to 15 south street
to form 20 residential flats
so the location plan is on screen and
the site is edged red it's a bit hard to
see but i'll follow it with the
follow up with this light so you can see
and it includes the access point to
leave a lane here and then extends
around here
so the built the main buildings are
three to fifteen south street which
front the eastern side of the road
the site also includes the modern
extensions of these buildings to the
rear
and the existing car park and the
existing walled garden which is in this
area here
there are purpose-built residential
flats to the eastern boundary so here
and here um and to the southern boundary
here is number 19 um which was in
council office use but has planning
permission to convert to residential
flats and then the old house
is tucked in the
southern corner here
in addition to the northern boundary the
site immediately adjacent to number one
south street which is a shop at ground
floor and has residential use above
the site is with within the rochard
conservation area and all of the
buildings fronting south street within
the site are grade two listed buildings
so the plan on screen
shows in red areas where demolition is
proposed and this is the ground floor
plan
the proposal seeks to demolish some of
the modern extensions to the rear so in
this area here
the rear of numbers three turtle really
five to seven
this would include the removal of the
single story building currently used as
the main council reception so that's
that's this bit here
and the single story links and
extensions surrounding this
so now on screen is the proposed first
floor demolition plan which again in red
shows proposed changes to the existing
buildings including the removal of some
of the modern partitions
oh sorry that's is that that's sorry
it's not these are not in the right
order
this is the proposed demolition plan at
first floor and you'll see that it it
shows some of the um
sort of demolition internal works to
remove some of these
modern partitions shown in red
this is to facilitate the new internal
layouts to create the residential flats
changing changes to existing windows and
doors are also proposed with the
proposal involving the replacement of
some of the existing windows and doors
to the rear so here also shown in red
you can see dotted about our changes so
that's really mainly to the rear
elevations of three to fifteen
the existing timber frame windows in the
detached building so these two detached
buildings well that's linked attached
but these two are to remain um and the
windows in these existing would be
replaced and the existing timber framed
windows replaced with aluminium framed
windows
some new
doors and windows are also proposed to
the rear elevations of three to fifteen
i'll come on to that in a little bit
more detail
as detailed in the committee report the
proposed replacement windows and doors
are all considered to be appropriate
given the context of this site in the
conservation area and also in respect to
preserving the historic value of the
list of buildings
i'll take you to the proposed
site layout
so as a result of the demolition
um to the rear of five to seven so in
this
area of the site
here
um this area would be opened up
and there isn't
hopefully you can see i might just zoom
in
so annotated with the letter b here this
is a proposed single story extension to
the rear of number seven
in addition this area that's now had the
buildings removed would be providing
additional car parking on site
a total of 20 car parking spaces will be
provided equating to one space per flat
which in this town centre location where
residents would have good access to
facilities and amenities on foot and
good access to public transport options
is considered acceptable
new hard and soft landscaping will be
provided in areas around and the new
extension between the car parking
some new tree planting is also proposed
so there's an additional tree planting a
tree to be planted here
one here and then there's also one
further down in the um existing wall
garden
two detached outbuildings were also
proposed so one to this northeastern
corner here that would serve as a refuse
store and one um to the northern
boundary of the wall guard and then that
would be a cycle store
take you to the proposed first floor
plan
so two residential flats would be
provided in each of the detached
modern buildings to be retained to the
rear one at ground floor and one at
first floor in each building
and there are existing windows at first
floor in both of these buildings which
will be used to serve proposed habitable
rooms a planning condition is
recommended to require that some of
these windows be fitted with obscure
glass
to protect the privacy of occupants of
nearby flats including millview court
to the east
and the flat and in the upper floors of
number one
otherwise it is considered that the
residential use of the buildings would
not give rise to harm to residential
amenity
i'll just take you to some of the
proposed elevations there are
quite a few submitted i should this one
first
so this plan shows the proposed front
elevation
of numbers three and five here
so this is the elevation that's fronting
south street
and limited works are proposed to the
front elevation of the list of buildings
of the whole frontage along south street
that includes numbers 9 11 13 and 15.
all windows and doors on this elevation
will be retained
but repaired and repainted where needed
other works proposed are detailed in the
committee report but include for
instance the repointing of the coping to
the parapet wall
just in this position here
and some of the repair to to render on
the front elevation
part of the i'll just zoom in
okay so this this elevation here so part
of the rear elevation of number seven is
shown here so that's the existing um
public access through to south street
and this shows that part of the proposed
single-story rear extension which would
have a parapet roof
above this you'll see um proposed a new
window
with a juliet balcony detail
you'll see alongside this although it's
very small but it's this point here so a
number of new vents are proposed but
these are contained towards to the rear
rather than the the main south street
elevation
i'll then show you the proposed rear
elevation of number seven in full
because this is this is where the
extension is proposed to the rear
so we've just seen part of it but this
is the full extent of that
rear elevation
this would feature new windows and doors
at ground floor level and these would
all be timber framed
so in conclusion works to propose listed
building include including the proposed
demolition extension internal and
external alterations and these works
require listed building consent and the
key consideration is whether the works
would result in harm to the significance
of the list of buildings
the council's specialist historic
buildings advisor at essex county
council is satisfied that the proposed
works would be appropriate
it is therefore recommended that the
application for listed building consent
at this site be approved subject to
recommended conditions
the proposed residential use of the
existing officers would be an
appropriate use in this town centre
location
the 20 flats proposed will be provided
with appropriate car parking and amenity
space and subject to the recommended
conditions and a section 106 legal
agreement at the heads of terms of which
is set out in the report the proposal
would satisfy relevant planning policy
considerations including relating to
affordable housing ecology flood risk
wheelchair accessible dwellings and
sustainable energy
it is therefore recommended chairman
that the application for planning
permission for this site for the
development also be approved subject to
the recommended conditions and section
106 legal agreement
thank you very much
okay mr viewers
to speak please
you know the format i'm not going to
tell you again
so good evening again chair members and
officers uh i'm now speaking on behalf
of the applicant in support of the
proposals for 3-15 south street
the anticipated future relocation of the
council services to the freight house
provides a valuable opportunity to
undertake the redevelopment of 3 to 15
south street such that it restores the
existing historic buildings and secures
their future for their sensitive through
their sensitive conversion back into
their original use as residential
accommodation
the regeneration site will deliver high
quality market and affordable housing
within the town centre community in
rockford
the application site is located within
the boundary of the rochester area
action plan
which requires previously developed
sites within rockford's existing
boundaries to be
efficiently used in order to safeguard
the surrounding metropolitan greenbelt
the proposed development also accords
with the policies of the adopted
development plan and the nppf
the application is brought to committee
following substantial pre-application
engagement with rdc and their advising
conservation officers
numbers 3 to 15 is effectively a
continuous building form fronting onto
south street
it comprises four individually listed
grade two buildings
adjacent but not within the site is the
grade 2 style listed 17 south street the
site is within the rockford conservation
area
the proposals deliver 20 residential
apartments 13 of which are for market
sale 7 apartments being affordable
to the rear of the site the proposals
include the demolition of this single
story infill extensions dating from the
latter half of the 20th century
this opens up the rear of the site to
provide additional vehicular parking
pedestrian walkways and semi-private
terraces to the new ground floor
apartments
where the removal of the 20th century
single-story extensions exposes the rear
of number seven south street a modest
single-story extension has been proposed
to reinstate this facade
the extension is proposed in red brick
to match the existing buildings with
traditional parapet wall and a
biodiverse flat roof
the heritage benefits of the proposals
include the restoration and repair to
the existing historic facades in
particular to the elevations fronting
south street internally the new
apartments have been laid out to retain
and in some cases reinstate historic
room proportions
in addition the historic party walls
that would have separated the buildings
when they were originally constructed as
individual houses have been retained
central staircases in their historic
locations are also maintained and so
collectively these design attributes
ensure the future legibility of the
historic building layout
historic front doors fronting onto south
street will be reopened to create a
renewed active frontage onto the street
and the existing carriage arch at number
nine south street is retained to provide
pedestrian access from south street
through the site
a detailed survey of the building has
allowed us to identify the remaining
historic fabric and detailing with the
proposals incorporating and retaining
these this is particularly concentrated
towards the southern end of the site
within number 15 south street where
historic doors cornicing and joinery
are to be restored
the walled garden to the rear of numbers
13 15 and south 17th house street is
retained along with the established
planting and mature trees providing
shared amenity for residents
many of the ground floor apartments also
have localized semi-private terraces
new secure and covered cycle storage is
provided on the footprint of an existing
outbuilding towards the northern end of
the walled garden and the proposals
provide 20 car parking spaces located to
the rear of the site and accessed via
the existing driveway via mill view
court three of these spaces are
wheelchair accessible six electric
vehicle charging points are provided
with service runs installed to assist
the installation of future additional
charging points when needed
the proposals strike a careful balance
between sensitive conservation of the
historic buildings whilst creating
residential dwellings that are
environmentally sustainable and meet
current and future needs of their
inhabitants
the development proposes to improve the
performance of the fabric of the
existing buildings wherever possible
this includes installing new insulating
lining to the internal face of existing
external walls
extinct existing windows to the rear
that are not historic are to be replaced
with thank you modern double glazing
historic windows are to be restored with
secondary double glazing installed
internally improving both the thermal
and acoustic insulation of the windows
as well as air tightness without
detriment to the historic external
appearance
photovoltaic solar panels are proposed
on the modern south facing roof
roof slopes to the rear the new
dwellings will be heated by internal air
source heat pumps discreetly located
within cupboards in each apartment
again there's no reliance on fossil
fuels so in summary the application
seeks to secure a viable future for the
site through restoration and conversion
of the historic buildings whilst
delivering 20 new environmentally
sustainable dwellings within the heart
of the community
thank you members for considering this
policy compliant application and i
invite you to support your office's
recommendation to grant planning consent
for this application thank you very
much we have one world member councillor
steptoe who has indicated that he wants
to speak on items seven and eight thank
you cancer
thank you chairman um i'd like to
address my comments that i made on the
last item to this item as well
that having been involved with this
since the original conception
i
would like to comment come into how well
the officers and
planning department and gb partnerships
have been working on this
over the years and it has been many
years
that has get to this particular stage
i have however
two items that have been raised by
residents that have asked me to put to
the members of the
committee and one item that i'd just
like to clarify ask members to clarify
for me
that item is with regards to the old
house although it's not part of his
planning application
the grounds at the back of the loud
house
and the old house is used for weddings
will that still remain available
for people if they wish to take
photographs
for use by the old house
uh will that there still be access for
the old house there
the items that have been raised by
residents
are mainly from the milford view court
which is the big grey block
in the middle of the picture there
most members i think will be very aware
of the limited access
through to the offices from millview
meadows
it comes down that little bit of road
just in front of the mill millview
court there which has got a bit of a dog
leg in it before we get into the car
park
two concerns that have been raised is
one from
particularly from the demolition point
of view although i know it's not a
material consideration but residents are
very concerned that is the only access
for
demolition vehicles
um i believe that the access is actually
owned by
sanctuary
and that
um we need to negotiate access through
that for the demolition vehicles
uh it's not an adopted highway so i'm
not sure how
strong that is going to be
for the heavier vehicles coming in and
out
secondly currently at the moment that is
the access for the car park for the
offices
now that's very limited that's only day
time
the office is closed i think the gates
close at around about seven o'clock when
everybody's gone home
how
is that going to be when they are become
flats
that's going to be the only vehicle
access
of people coming in and out
how is that going to affect residents
and i would ask the committee to perhaps
ask how that's going to be mitigated
particularly as millview court is
sheltered accommodation
and i have on a couple of occasions over
the years when i've tried to come in
there there's been an ambulance there
um and that can block the entrance there
so i have a concern and i would ask
members of the committee to perhaps
consider that
having said all of that chairman i'm
fully uh
um supportive of the application and uh
very much like and hope that it will go
forward thank you very much
any other
visiting members would like to comment
on this
please no indication i will now go on to
the committee and
the other member here tonight is
councillor williams would you like to
say something
thank you chairman um
once again councillor scepter has stolen
my thunder um the access the only
vehicular access to this is via
um mill view meadows
and through the private road that runs
to the
north of mill view cool and there is
also pedestrian access to mill view
caught the only pedestrian exits um on
that road so i have i do have concerns
regarding
um the the construction traffic once
again so i would like to see something
put in for the mitigation of that thank
you
thank you
officers
yes
is that is that on yeah
um
there has been a construction management
plan um submitted and there's a
condition requiring um
it to be um carried out in accordance
with that
but i mean ultimately they're going
we're going to have to utilize that
existing access for construction so
um i don't think it would be a planning
reason to refuse an application you know
so it will just have to be managed as
successfully as it can
um you know bearing in mind the
um sort of sensitive use of milview
court adjacent but um we'd expect you
know contractors to you know
be considerate in their practices um but
ultimately we consider that this this
access is acceptable for construction um
and it wouldn't be a
consideration on which to refuse this
application
[Music]
thank you jimmy just a quick question on
the construction side if there's any
damage done by the construction
is there anything in the um
proposal to uh that they have to rectify
any damage that has that they may cause
if it's going through a private road
obviously
thank you
and again it's it's not a matter for the
planning application to consider or
impose any um it wouldn't be appropriate
to propose any conditions or the like um
in respect for planning consent it will
be a private matter between parties
thank you cancer sterling
thank you german um i don't know if it's
a planning matter but um
with the refuge um
where did you say the all the refuge
bins were were to be put for collection
and can the
refuge lorry or
turn round and and drive in and out or
is it just a reverse in all the way
thank you
can you hear me yes um so
the refuse store is proposed here
so in the northeast corner of the site
and my understanding is that existing
waste is collected from the rear car
parking area
in any case so it would be kind of no
different to the existing situation
other than the fact that the waste being
collected is residential waste not
commercial
i think my understanding is that the
refuse truck does reverse down this this
route
into the site and that would be
maintained that would be
continued
and councillor
and councillor stanley again on 7.7 3.84
refuse collection will be from liber
lane as per the existing waste
arrangements
thank you
what the the reason that i ask this is
that there's two bins
per flat or is there only going to be
one bin per flat
till that's in this report as well
yes okay sorry about that
he isn't cut he's included
flatted schemes generally have communal
waste refuse bins so they share a number
of bins but that that the refuse store
is sized appropriately for the 20 flats
thank you council foster thank you
chairman um
being as how this is um
in a fairly intense residential area do
we have any conditions limiting the
hours of working
no we don't have a condition limiting
hours of working can we include that
then please
yeah
um
we don't as a general rule put planning
conditions on restricting the hours of
operation but it would be um
again part of the sort of considerate
contractors um
we wouldn't expect them to work you know
unreasonable hours um but we haven't put
forward a condition that would limit it
specifically
so um
our environmental health team um would
be
if if the construction was
too early in the morning or was carrying
on unsociable hours
it would be picked up by the
environmental health team under a
statutory noise nuisance
and i mean there is guidance that's out
there for developers and contractors
under the considerate contractors
guidance
it's um you know it's not usual practice
for us to actually put conditions on
they actually become quite difficult to
actually enforce
can i just come back on that police
chair yes of course you can um i am
aware that this committee has actually
passed conditions in the past limiting
hours of working yeah and in this
particular case i think it's
particularly relevant uh being as how
you've got a lot of old and infirm
people living in mill view court if
you've got heavy vehicles going through
there at seven o'clock in the morning or
on saturday afternoon which it doesn't
matter if you're considerate a
contractor this still happens
if you have a defined time that people
are actually allowed to work there i
would suggest that that would be a
quite reasonable to expect that as being
conditions in that particular area
yeah i mean obviously when we impose
conditions they have to pass the six
tests
and one of those tests is that it's
actually reasonable
um i mean obviously we would expect the
contractors to actually um
not to actually sort of do any
development work on sociable times and
as i previously mentioned
the um if if it was that developers were
actually you know starting work
unreasonable hours and causing a
nuisance to enabling residents then it
would be picked up by environmental
health i think the only thing it's very
difficult to actually
impose a condition like this and and you
are right councillor eaves we have
imposed conditions like that before and
they've actually been very difficult to
enforce it raises an expectation for the
residents
and um
i mean i'm sure that you're you know
you're aware of some of those
applications where we've done that and
actually it's been very difficult to
actually enforce
well personally i'd like to propose that
we do actually uh
include conditions i do understand
exactly what you're saying but i think
that my
my experience of the building industry
is you can put those in
uh
as a part of the considerate
contractor um conditions but you will
find that if they don't have a defined
time then they will be able to negotiate
those times wider that is the
practicality of what actually happens
yeah
we can put it on as an informative to
warp to actually as guidance for the
contractor i'd like to see something on
there yes please yeah okay so we'll
we'll actually put that in can we
suggest at times that that would be
relevant yeah normally it would be not
before seven o'clock in the morning
after and after six in the evening and
weekends weekends is normally saturday
mornings
six till one and then no uh six till one
or seven to one seven sorry seven two
one seven till one and then no um no
sundays and no bank holidays okay that
would be appreciated if we can put that
on there's a
recommendation please thank you thank
you much before i go to council foster i
just want to go to councillor steptoe if
you look on sevenpoint
of the papers
3.81 it does tell you about the gardens
and the photography okay just want to
clarify that council foster thank you
chairman i'm
hesita hesitate say great buy and think
alike but council reeves has just
covered one of my points
um
an observation and a question the access
road i've noticed and going to the
council offices is narrowed by the
hedgerow along that top edge being
overgrown and
rarely if ever trimmed back that's quite
a significant amount of overhang
um the question i have is
the subject of pedestrian access to
millview court was raised and the
problem of that being through that
narrow road is there any possibility
that that access to the court could be
via the entrance at south street through
the where the development needs
just a question doesn't need to be
answered now it's a thought to put on
all right thank you
well that is are you
awesome
will be via
lever lane and out through and there is
another um footpath access down
to the sort of south street
keys lane i think it's called
that's out this way but the development
site itself does not propose to provide
pedestrian through route
for other residents in the wider
vicinity
um
if i may i'm just suggesting it may be
considered
thank you
members before we start um
we've had a meeting that's gone on for
over two hours um
we could take a short
ten minute comfort break if required
but i'd like to move a motion um without
notice called in committee procedures
rule 9n to extend this meeting beyond
two and a half hours for as long as it's
practical in order to complete the
business can i have a seconder
thank you i don't think it will go on
forever you know for a long time do we
members do we want the 10 minute break
or shall
we want to carry on yeah can we have a
comment i need you to vote on that i
know it takes a bit of time but can i
just have a vote
you you're not voting council williams
you right are you you're right thank you
uh councillor williams are you what are
you for against
right thank you
okay so you'll be leaving after ten
o'clock
okay thank you i just want to clarify
that members um is there anyone else
would like to speak on this or i'll go
to the recommendation
no
right we have a recommendation of for
approval members um
they're set out on paragraph 1.1 of the
report on pages 7.1 through to 7.10 of
the report with amended conditions 2 10
and 29
as set out on pages 2 and 3 of the
addendum
i'd like to move the motion for
recommendation have a secondary
please oh we've got a couple of you
forever i've got three of you thank you
thank you very much can i have a vote
members for
all in favor please
that's unanimous thank you members item
10 has been uh no
item 8 has been
discussed so
we'll go straight to the recommendation
unless councillor septo wants to speak
on this
no other members
i might think he will go straight to the
recommendation that is
um we put a motion on that it's for
approval can i have a second to please
daniel the councillor
thank you all members can i have a show
of hands all in favor please
that's unanimous thank you members i
will end the meeting at
9 56. thank you members for a very good
meeting
you